Jim does many jujitsu Jim still open
right now or no nope Wow Kim that's
crazy
the pros are still getting the work in
but like the classes and that you can't
you can't do it dude I saw a black guy
in the park by my apartment yesterday
trying to fly a kite and it was a
[ __ ] was there any wind I don't know
if those win or not but it was the most
I don't think there was and it was the
most [ __ ] weirdest thing I've ever
seen in my life
depressing right yeah just seemed like
an erectile dysfunction video like one
of the hoods get you down it was just
like it would go like 12 feet or 8 feet
of just [ __ ] crash but but it's
different times brah especially those
black dudes flying kites bro that's when
you know the [ __ ] this is the end come
have some [ __ ] respect dawg you think
our [ __ ] roll dog right here [ __ ]
with kites son you don't know you don't
know it's hired him on the spot what is
this guy YZ what is Remember the Titans
or Friday Night Lights better miss Deniz
when I'm 11 let's start in the culture
corner I know where you guys has
everybody seen both shows I've never
seen Friday Night Lights I've seen the
movie not the show and red wine
understand me either you haven't seen
the show mm-hmm give it to you've seen
it it was on CW yeah well you never seen
Friday Night Lights movie go watch find
out bro during this thing you're
thinking about what do i watch i watch
oh I always are just a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] always works the same episode over
and over again don't ruin it for me huh
I just start season - you'll be fine
yeah it's the same yester trying to
hustle laundry money for the cartel yeah
it never ends very lasting it's [ __ ]
the show is so exhausted exhausted it's
like we did it and they're like good job
now fifty million yeah [ __ ] dude
it's basically 30 episodes trying to
decide if the sister is hot or not
that's what I feel like oh yeah you know
is she of age huh she of age yeah she
just have that one sex scene in the boat
he does season one oh I think wife's a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] though and she what
mean yeah you know so much Friday that
lights though bro remember the time
Remember the Titans yeah I remember it
hayden Panettiere is a little girl in it
but she knows defense and [ __ ] mmm I was
like Nick Saban remember the back of my
dick dude short side left side Oh Friday
Night Lights is the best for me it goes
Breaking Bad Friday Night Lights what do
you thin it I haven't seen I know chin
hasn't seen it Nick you've only seen
Remember the Titans yeah I've seen the
movie Friday Night Lights and I read the
book back in the day when I worked at
the library in high school but throw
that in there wait look way to dry my
erection Oh bring the shutter screeching
home you still books and [ __ ] I just
read magazines and newspapers you know
library still booming not really right
can you just reach it whenever you want
you just read stuff online or get the
book online go to the library what I
think you bring up a good point yeah
like why would anybody go to a library
now first of all I can listen you ever
discuss with oh that's crazier than
[ __ ] [ __ ] nothing is [ __ ] check
since the guy with the Rugrats [ __ ]
hoodie on right now
sweet hoodie bad baby this is one of one
bro you [ __ ] right in this watashi
out Nick that doesn't even drive over
[Laughter]
man nobody I put it was good man
[Music]